toutes les femmes bonnes administes ne
sont pas les mêmes que les femmes moi de
quelqu'un qui touchent 1200 1300 euros
par mois mais je vois des chiffres qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux sur le
montant de rémunération des ministres
qui sont totalement faux ma rémunération
et totalement transparente j'ai
7450 € net par mois une fois les impôts
déduits j'ai une famille j'ai 4 enfants
je fais mes courses je paye mon
alimentation et c'est bien normal
contrairement à ce qu'il dit dans les
réseaux sociaux je n'occupe pas mon
logement de fonction je paye mon loyer
voilà c'est des choses qui méritent
d'être dites je ne vois pas pourquoi les
politiques seraient mieux traiter que
les autres mais je vois pas pourquoi il
serait moins bien traité
les
dis la vérité il gagne 7450 euros
j'imagine quand même que ces journées
il a réussi je suis désolé et puis là
donner leur salaire lui au moins il
donne son salaire il est pas démago
s'il a fait des années
j'ai une personne que j'adore personne
qui nous regarde tous les soirs c'est
j'appelle ma sister c'est Cathy que
j'adore elle me met c'est énorme par
rapport à moi mais c'est pas exorbitant
par rapport à son statut je trouve
qu'elle a vraiment résumé ça voilà elle
a résumé
la transparence
quand il y aura des lobbies qui
viendront les soudoyer parce qu'ils sont
pas assez payés et que justement ils
accepteront ses potes comment dans les
autres pays vous ne parlez toujours des
autres pays et 8 9000 balles 10000
balles en Suède ils allaient ils
allaient travailler pour que tu racontes
ça vous va moi ça me va très bien pour
moi il ne produisent rien ils sont payés
j'ai envie d'avoir la vie de Gilbert je
suis pas payé d'accord avec moi non pas
du tout je suis scandalisé de Gilles
Verdez c'est de l'argent public Cyril la
population de la République le Premier
ministre gagne environ 15000 bruts c'est
énorme
vous gagnez combien
je vais crever la tête
en public
[Applaudissements]
les gars je le dis et moi je suis pas et
là voilà il faut avoir les les
ici il y en a qui gagnent plus que le
ministre de l'Économie le gars et je
vais vous dire c'est pas les ministres
voilà c'est pas voilà c'est Bruno Le
Maire là c'est Noël Mamère
responsabilité
qui nous paye on a pas de voiture
ne parle pas d'un niveau d'études je
vous parle l'homme me dites pas que ça
vous fait rien de savoir que des mecs
plein de mecs touchent 7400 € comme ça
et des chroniqueurs qui gagnent 7000
balles mais peut-être peut-être les
chroniqueurs qui gagnent 7000
gagne plus que Bruno Le Maire ici le
vélo
tu peux lever là-bas Raymond tu gagnes
pas j'ai touché cette somme là quand
j'ai fait mes 13e mois avec mon tarif
quand je travaille sur RTL et quand je
travaille ici
alors quand tu veux vous savez on fait
un truc très simple vous voulez jouer à
celui-là
la semaine plus de couilles on va bien
jouer au jeu j'aime bien cette séquence
combien tu gagnes par mois combien tu
gagnes par jour combien tu gagnes
déclaration d'impôts ce soir on va la
ramener la déclaration d'impôts la pose
tous sur la table
refuser il m'a refusé tout le monde a
refusé carrément
[Applaudissements]
que le ministre de l'économique
c'est normal mais c'est fou non c'est
pas normal je suis d'accord c'est pas
normal après c'est plus 450 ça fait
quand même 11600 brutes ce qui a choqué
c'est quand il a dit j'ai une famille
nombreuse à nourrir sous-entendu je suis
en galère
il a une boîte de prod lui il emploie
des jantes emploi des gens toi des gens
tu donnes tu fais des chèques il emploie
des gens
arrêtez
il est plus utile
notre pays ah super c'est pas rien tu
vois de démagogie
[Musique]
chinois
4020 ça suffisait largement à 4000
balles il est pas trop payé il produit
de la richesse dans le monde qu'est-ce
que
c'est combien en maillot c'est combien
en endroit 10 mois c'est combien en
place de ça mais vous êtes compares
Mbappé avec lui
mais combien d'impôts ils payent des
impôts tu les impôts qu'on lui a donné
non n'importe quoi une minute que lui
gagnera qu'est-ce que tu racontes est-ce
que tu peux est-ce que tu penses est-ce
que tu te rends compte que par exemple
ici je pense qu'il y a des gens qui
viennent plus que le Président de la
République ou ici ici sur le plateau
peut-être que tu payes trop léger on
monte les échelons mais peut-être
mais peut-être que ces gens-là vont
grâce à la pub que tu sur ton émission
arrête de les payer ce prix là je te le
dire tout le monde à 4000 rapporté je le
saurai tu vois Kelly vedobelix vous en
pensez euh non on a dit que c'était le
ministre de l'Économie donc ouais je
pense que il a la statue pour qu'il soit
payé à ce point-là après quand on voit
l'économie en France on se pose aussi
des questions en fait il y a tout qui
est à remettre en question à ce
moment-là mais je pense qu'on peut pas
tout comparer non plus on peut pas
comparer le fait que lui soit ministre
et que ce soit l'argent public après
nous bah on peut pas se comparer
c'est pas de l'argent c'est pas de
l'argent public
quand tu es petit on te dit un truc on
te dit tu travailles bien à l'école tu
seras fixé et tu seras récompensé et tu
auras un beau métier tu auras un beau
travail il a bien travaillé à l'école
c'est faux mais c'est faux en vrai tous
les travail les plus durs c'est travail
les moins payés exactement c'est ceux
qui touche le plus d'oseille
je comprends ta colère je discute moi je
vais te dire une chose moi je suis un
milieu extrêmement modeste où j'étais
très heureux on vivait dans la HLM on
était très heureux pas un rond je me
suis démerdé toute ma vie parce que je
voulais pas vivre comme mes parents
voilà j'ai la chance maintenant j'ai 66
ans d'avoir d'arriver à gagner un peu
plus d'argent que d'habitude à vivre
plus confortablement mais c'est du
boulot je me suis fait chier toute ma
vie même si heureusement je fais un
métier passionnant et je suis très
heureux dans ce métier et c'est le
mérite
la même chose que toi c'est le même
chemin que toi je suis en train de dire
que c'est les métiers les plus durs
je gagne beaucoup d'argent parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé excuse-moi
justement
j'ai beaucoup travaillé c'est la
méritocratie
il y a une infirmière qui se lève à 5h
du matin et qui gagne voilà le problème
qui voit l'autre connard de monter sur
une chaise
[Applaudissements]
la tête dans les mots
applaudit
je l'adore ça l'a mis il faut pas avoir
peur du coup faut pas poser riche
le problème c'est l'infirmière qui
touche pas assez c'est pas grave
l'infirmière
ils ambulanciers des études parce qu'ils
peuvent parce qu'ils ont les parents
pourraient
pas une tu crois que les je crois que
les personnes qui sont dans le
gouvernement ils se réveillent à quelle
heure ça travaille quand même moi je
pense qu'un maçon il travaille plus
qu'un ministre je suis désolé les maçons
moi j'ai des boules mais je te lance un
boulanger je pense qu'un jour
alors qu'un ministre il peut dégager du
jour au lendemain et on retourne
pas les gens se rendent pas compte du
jour au lendemain ça fait 38 ans
d'ailleurs c'est demain moi les virer ça
toi bien sûr
c'est fini très vite et dans ces cas-là
les charges sont les mêmes tout le monde
connaît ça
ferme avec des ouvriers sur le carré
elle a pénibilité la pénibilité il faut
prendre en compte évidemment moi
j'aimerais que tout le monde soit
augmenter évidemment enfin j'ai commis
ça dans ma vie mon père était contrôleur
de route SNCF on a gardé une bagnole je
crois que pendant 20 ans tu vois
d'accord je connais j'ai connu ça non
plus ça n'est pas entendable qu'on a on
sait pas ce qu'on va faire l'année
prochaine de des entreprises qui ferment
il y en a tous les jours avec des
ouvriers
on peut le dire je l'aime mais je ne te
dis pas que tu as moi je suis très
content que tu gagnes beaucoup d'argent
tu l'as pas volé il y a pas de souci
je peux te comprendre